>>> FLORIDA'
DISNEY COMNG A
BILL O GOVERNSTATUS.
FTER DISNEY OBCTLAW PROHIBITING
IDS ABOUT XU GIDENTITY.
GO SIGNING
REIOTH
THE DEVELOPS IN
MIAM
EXPECTED TO  IMPACTS
FLORIANHAS EXACTLY RIGHT,
FRA.
OD MORNIE GOVE O
CONGRENAL G MATHATRI SAY DIMINE.
MAP, THE ONE
THATVES
T PICKING
NAL SEATS
LATER TH A NUMBER OF CIVIL EDLAL
NOW, THE LEGISTUOF
TH PASSED EAR  OF THINGS,
E OR WAS ABLE TO GET
TE TO
OUND THE ODO AREA.T THAT MOVE W
IN
N'AWONE BIG QUESTI HERE,LOOMING?
DEE AT THAT MONEY D SE
DISNEY DID AWAWITH AN THAT THE A
THO D HE KEISOF DISNEY.
MYIEW THATA PROVOCATION TO ATTT
AND WE'RE GOING TO FIG B
.
>>orO TH TEND IST GO INTO EFFECH
HAMM O NEW AGREEMENT,  HOW TIS
THE GOVERNOR ALSO BILL THAS WITP
RACEENA WSUIT NSSOIL ALL RIGHT,
THANU H FOR THAT.
>>> LET'S TALK MOREYHERE WITH UA
COLLECTOR FOR GE FLORIDA, WHICH
OF THEWORLOPERTIES,
SCOT.OOD TO SEE.ISRE PRETTMP
ISN'T IT STRIP DISNE
SPECIAL PPENED
IFTAX BURDEN INTO LOCA
WILL ORGEY MAKE
UP T THAS  QUESTIO
Y IS A HUGR  REPUBLICA IN FLOR
TO GNTFIGHT, WOULDBACK ANDOPE PN
I REPRES1.N PEOP
IN ORANGCO WHOHTUCK WITH $163 AA
TAXI DT TS RESOLVED,
TY NE 163MI COUNTSI
U THINK THE GOVERNOR T LITTLEHA
STATUS?NETS APECIAL TRE NOTAYR O
EYHEIRTAXE EYN  TO
TH T TTH
PROVIDSERVICES AROUND TH PRORT L
SVI
INCIDENTIONS ONEY
CONTROL.
THEYAVN POWEPLANT,STE WATER,NK
ALL
ORANGE COUNHE
THERS EY THAT
COMES WITH THAT.
ONE SIDE OZERO ANDER S GOI
TO SAY NEGATIV16LLION.
ICES, DE CANY  SERCEAT IH G  HLV
OSHA
RNMENT HE TO M M
THA NE
DIS N INCOT  C THEY CAN'T DOTAXP
END OF THE DAY, YOU KNOW, AGAINS
TACR SIDENT. TGE PG AS PROPERT
>> IF YOU'RE AY IULD 0, $300 A.
THIS IS ANOS. RUN A BUSINESS RA
CO LOOKING AT
THOUSANDS OFOL
ISE ICALLY, THEYE PAYING
TENS OLA
DEBT.
BT.'SALERE AROU
HOW WILL TT INTO
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY KN
ACTUAL AMOUNT.S JUSTE PAL.D  BU
ALL THAT IS REALLY K FOR O ORANY
SURE IS THEYS N YE
COLLECT IN
ORDER TO SERVICE THAT E COUNTYL
IMATHAVEND8 R JUST
VICE TDEBT.
>> SO WE JUST RT, WE HAVE --SAYP
EFFECT?
YOT PEOPLE MAY EARING THIS FOTII
SO ANY CHANGEST WOULD HAS ONLYO
OLLSO J
>> NOT FROY --
>> NOTEAUNTY. COUNTY'OP
OR -BASNEYR OM OIO SLI WATER
O DISNATO VER
HAVE TO AHASSEE  SIGOULD
ICH  WF THIS BAN
L TALLAHASSE?TION DATE IS A AR A
BU
YOE  U, WH
ERE, WHY WOU
A STAT CHANGED
72-HOUR TIME PERIOTION
>>M NO PSYI'R
OC
S FUNNYPE
THAT'
AGLIKE, YOU CAN' LIKE THIS.
YBK HAD OUTLIVED
BU SAYRO ON
NAT MAKING
OE LYIMPOSSANGES LIKE
NGY  THE LASTHIN DOR
GOR
ANNG
>> THAT'S EXACTLAH. RIGHT --
WEOT AEL.
SORRMES STEPYO SRY
UT
MOVING